DOM.
THE PRESIDENT AND ANYONE ELSE IN
ROBERT MUELLER’S SITES DESERVE
IT TOO, AND THAT’S THE ANGLE.
IF JOINING US FROM WASHINGTON
ARE TWO HOUSE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
SEEN IT THESE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS.
RAUL LABRADOR FROM IDAHO AND ANY
PICKS FROM ARIZONA.
WERE ALSO JOINED BY FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR BYRON YORK, IT’S
GREAT TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN LABRADOR, I WANT TO
START WITH YOU.
I STARTED GETTING CALLS, I’M
HERE ON THE WEST COAST -- I’M I
STARTED GETTING CALLS ABOUT THIS
AT ABOUT 6:30 IN THE MORNING BY
CONGRESSMAN WHO STARTED TO READ
THIS REPORT AND THEY DIDN’T
REVEAL ANYTHING THEY WEREN’T
SUPPOSED TO.
THEY SAID WHATEVER YOU DO, THE
PEOPLE HAVE TO KNOW WHAT IS IN
THIS, THIS HAS TO GET
DECLASSIFIED.
TELL US HOW WE CAN DECLASSIFY IT
AND WHATEVER YOU CAN TELL US
ABOUT WHAT’S INSIDE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON YOUR
SHOW, THIS IS SO IMPORTANT AND
IT’S IMPORTANT FOR YOUR VIEWERS
TO KNOW THAT THE HOUSE HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO RELEASE THIS
INFORMATION.
WE DON’T HAVE TO DECLASSIFY IT.
HOUSE RULE TEN AND THIS IS
SOMETHING I THINK WERE GOING TO
TALK A LOT ABOUT OVER THE NEXT
FEW WEEKS, IT ALLOWS US TO
SELECT THE COMMITTEE TO RELEASE
THE INFORMATION, THEY BELIEVE IT
IS IMPORTANT ENOUGH TO THE
PUBLIC THAT IS OF VITAL
IMPORTANCE TO THE PUBLIC.
ALL WE NEED TO DO IS HAVE A VOTE
FROM THE HOUSE AND THE HOUSE
SELECT COMMITTEE CAN DO THAT.
I THINK WE NEED TO DO THAT
IMMEDIATELY.
IN THE NEXT WEEK OR SO I BELIEVE
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO SEE
EVERYTHING THAT IS IN THIS
DOCUMENT.
I CAN’T TELL YOU, CONGRESSMAN
BIGS CAN’T TELL YOU WHAT WE READ
TODAY BUT PEOPLE WILL BE
SHOCKED.
>> Laura: WE ARE GOING TO HIT
ON THIS IMMIGRATION DEBATE AND
THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN, ON THIS
ISSUE OF THE RELEASE OF THIS
REPORT, IS THERE ANY NATIONAL
SECURITY CONCERN ABOUT RELEASING
THIS DOCUMENT THAT YOU CAN SEE?
ANYTHING THAT PAUL RYAN COULD
POINT TO TO AVOID A MOVE?
>> I SAW NOTHING THAT RELEASING
TO THE PUBLIC WOULD HAVE ANY
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON THE NATIONAL
INTEREST, I THINK THE NATIONAL
INTEREST IS HARMED BY KEEPING IT
A SECRET TO THE PUBLIC.
WE HAVE TO BE TRANSPARENT, WE
HAVE TO GET THIS OUT THERE.
IT IS SO VITAL, SO IMPORTANT.
AMERICANS ARE GOING TO BE AS
OUTRAGED AND MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE READ THIS.
IT HAS TO GET OUT AND I DON’T
BELIEVE WE CAN HIDE BEHIND THE
SHIELD OF NATIONAL SECURITY
INTEREST BECAUSE THE PROBLEM IS
JUST FLIPPED ON ITS HEAD.
IT WAS DEMOCRATS IN THAT
COMMITTEE WHO DON’T WANT IT
RELEASED.
>> Laura: I WANTED TO GO TO
YOU ON THIS, I HEARD FOUR
PEOPLE -- CONGRESSMAN THIS
MORNING.
PEOPLE VERY HIGH UP IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI
COULD VERY WELL LOSE THEIR JOBS
IF THIS REPORT GOES PUBLIC.
DO YOU BELIEVE GIVEN WHAT WE’VE
HEARD FROM GLENN SIMPSON, HE’S
TRYING TO MOVE ON THE DOSSIER
WITH THE OLD ADMINISTRATION, HOW
EXPLOSIVE COULD THIS BE?
>> IT COULD BE PRETTY EXPLOSIVE.
HAVEN’T ACTUALLY SEEN THE
DOCUMENT BUT WE’VE BEEN HEARING
ABOUT THIS FOR QUITE A LONG
WHILE.
THE INVESTIGATORS IN THE HOUSE
HAVE BEEN IN A BOX FOR MONTHS.
IF THEY HAVE BEEN LEARNING
THINGS OF GREAT PUBLIC INTEREST
BUT IT WAS CLASSIFIED AND THEY
COULDN’T TELL THE PUBLIC.
THE INSTITUTION HAD THE
AUTHORITY TO DECLASSIFY WAS THE
INSTITUTION THEY WERE
INVESTIGATING.
IT’S A TRAP, WHAT WE SAW TODAY
WAS A BRILLIANT EFFORT TO BUST
OUT OF THAT, USE A MANEUVER TO
CREATE A SUMMARY OF THEIR WORK
AND ALLOW ALL MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSE TO SEE IT.
IT WASN’T A SMALL GROUP OF 13
PEOPLE ON THE REPUBLICANS, IT
WAS ANYBODY IN THE HOUSE THAT
COULD TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
IT WAS REALLY BIG AND THAT WAS
INCREASING THE MOMENTUM TO TRY
THIS PARLIAMENTARY MANEUVER THAT
REPRESENTATIVE LABRADOR HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: THE DEMOCRATS WERE
OKAY WITH RELEASING THE GLENN
WE ARE GOING TO PLAY A SNIPPET
OF THAT, IT’S IMPORTANT FOR THEM
TO SEE THE FOUNDER OF THE
FUSION GPS SAID.
IT’S FULL SCREEN SORRY ABOUT
THAT.
HE WAS ASKED TO DO THE FBI EVER
REACH OUT TO YOU OR FUSION GPS,
HE SAID NO.
YOU’VE NEVER HEARD FROM ANYONE
INSIDE THE GOVERNMENT, THE FBI
OR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
DURING THE ELECTION, NO.
WHAT DID YOU HEAR AFTER?
I WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
IT WAS BY A PROSECUTOR NAMED
BRUCE OR WHO FOLLOWED UP.
IN OTHER WORDS NELLY OR WHO
WORKED FOR FUSION GPS, HE ENDED
UP BEING THE SOURCE OF THE
QUESTION.
CONGRESSMAN LABRADOR YOUR
REACTION TO THAT.
>> I CAN’T SPEAK ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC FACTS BECAUSE I SAW
THIS MEMO TODAY, I HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL.
THE DEMOCRATS DECIDED TO VOTE
AGAINST RELEASING THIS MEMO.
WHEN I WAS IN THE ROOM AND I
HEARD FROM OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS WHEN THEY WERE IN THE
ROOM, THERE WERE NO DEMOCRATS
WHO ACTUALLY CAME DOWN TO LOOK
AT THIS MEMO.
THEY WERE SO INTERESTED IN THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION STORY UNTIL IT
STARTED UNRAVELING, NOW WE HAVE
SOME INFORMATION, WE WERE
UNWILLING TO RELEASE IT OR EVEN
LOOK AT IT.
I THINK WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL FIND, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SHOCKED BY THIS MEMO.
I INVITE EVERYBODY TO USE THE
#ReleaseTheMemo , WE NEED TO
PUSH THE HOUSE LEADERSHIP TO DO
THIS.
I HOPE THAT THEY DO AND THEY
STAND WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Laura: WE ARE WAY OUT OF
TIME, WE COULD DO AN HOUR ON
THIS.
ARE PEOPLE GOING TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS?
>> THEY PROBABLY OUGHT TO.
I’M SHOCKED THAT SOME HAVEN’T
ALREADY.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT,
GENTLEMEN, FASCINATING.
WE DIDN’T HAVE TIME TO GET INTO
THE IMMIGRATION BILL THAT THE